[Música]
quién no ha soñado alguna vez con viajar
en el tiempo verdad bueno en mi caso
casi podríamos decir que casi lo consigo
mira esta es mi máquina del tiempo
veréis a lo largo de mi trayectoria he
tenido la oportunidad de convivir y
fotografiar diferentes formas de vida
tribus pueblos siempre viajando
alrededor del mundo eso es algo que yo
ya preveía hace 29 años cuando comencé y
desde luego esa idea ya solo ya me
apasionaba pero lo que no me podría
haber imaginado jamás es que mi
profesión me haría viajar en el tiempo
y si tuve esa sensación muchísimas veces
cuando fotografié por ejemplo la
comunidad menonita pude hacerme una idea
clara y nítida de cómo vivía el ser
humano hace un par de siglos o al
fotografiar comunidades autóctonas de
áfrica
mi mente se trasladaba en un viaje en el
tiempo aún mayor aún más lejano
de alguna manera podríamos decir que
para mí mi máquina fotográfica se había
convertido justo en eso en una especie
de máquina del tiempo
y en ese sentido sin lugar a dudas la
experiencia más intensa la vivienda la
amazonas junto a la tribu de los mayor
unas bueno imaginaron totalmente
abstraído del mundo exterior y rodeado
de fauna y flora selvática fue donde me
trasladé a la forma de vida más
primitiva
tanto así que bueno en el pasado el ser
humano más desarrollado era justo así
claro yo para subsistir el tiempo que
estuve allí con ellos pues llevaba en mi
mochila una serie de víveres entre los
que por supuesto también se encontraba
evidentemente latas de conservas
y fueron éstas las que le llama
poderosísimamente la atención se
quedaban mirando las las tocaban las
cogían en peso se reían tímidamente
entre ellos bueno yo la verdad que no
dudé ni un momento en regalarles algunas
de ellas a modo de agradecimiento
sabéis qué hicieron con las latas de
conservas
o lo imagináis
las plantaron
plantaron la lata de conservas claro eso
que por aquel entonces me hizo también
bastante gracia también me hizo
reflexionar muchísimo sobre nuestra
evolución a lo largo del paso del tiempo
con respecto al homo sapiens que una vez
fuimos
que estamos haciendo en nuestro tiempo
acaso en el futuro vamos a poder
comernos nuestros móviles las tablets
vamos a poder respirar wifi
la verdad que me quedé un poco
desconcertado al ver como una persona
que vive anclada en nuestro pasado más
primitivo me estaba haciendo reflexionar
precisamente acerca de nuestro futuro
mira da igual hacia donde queramos
evolucionar
así que estamos evolucionando que son
otras da igual a donde queremos
progresar al final del final del final
lo que nos va a quedar va a ser eso lo
que podamos sembrar lo que podamos
cultivar
está claro que no podemos inventarnos
otros planetas
estamos plantando el futuro que queremos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]